I do feel like when I'm at work when I'm
on set when I'm like doing a show that
is probably where I'm the most myself
um because I love it and I work hard at
it and I'm ready when I get there like I
have a exhaustive sort of prep process
and then I throw it all away once I'm on
set and I'm just there and so I I
appreciate that you saw me that way
um because that's kind of
yeah that's how you feel that's how yeah
that's how so are you saying that
there's sort of a juxtaposition of like
you're on set that's your world of
confidence but in the real world maybe
you're not as
you know I think I'm not as with the
like publicity side of it and doing
interviews and like the Press support
you have to do for projects why is that
you think you know it just feels like a
different kind of attention on you it
feels like much more pressure it feels
like
um more personal I guess and when you're
playing a character you are you get to
hide behind that and like you're acting
and it's a performance and that's kind
of where my strength is and then when it
gets to like you know the personal stuff
I always start just like get I get
anxiety I sort of shut down okay what do
I say what do I do I hate when things
like
guys sometimes you don't want attention
on things
that see that this is this is normal
this is like you know
um when you do red carpets sure I bet
you hate that I don't mind the red
carpet why is that because I you have to
pose like Kristen Kristen over here
Kristen you have to put that little
mouth kind of chin thing down and yeah
and everybody does it every all the
women the actresses yeah older dudes you
have to kind of you know what how you
look good and you have to do that yeah
but do you ever get mad at yourself for
oh why am I putting that on
if you don't put it on like if I don't
do like something you're gonna look like
I look like an idiot I look stupid
because I I don't photograph as easily
easy easily as well as you do and so I
get a little bit like I have to go
um we're at goofy or something I don't
mind the red carpet the photographs I'm
like I before I was an actress I was a
model so I had that like kind of built
into the work like that's part of the
work for me
um it's the interview Parts afterwards
it's the talk shows it's those things
that like you know what's the first
interview you have to say who it was but
do you ever have one experience where
you're like
um I'm done
um I didn't not one that I was I was
like I'm done but I feel like you know
whenever you're supporting a project and
you have to do like the talk show
circuit I would always have just put so
much pressure on myself and I'd be like
in the dressing room like like panicking
breaking out in hives and sweating and
nobody would sort of believe me or like
validate that because like you got this
Kristen your interviews are always great
you got this and I'm like no really I'm
I'm so nervous I can't do it I can't do
it but then you do it and you like work
the nerves you use the nerves to like
make a cute appearance and then it's
over and then everyone's like see you
got this but
it's the cyclical thing yeah it doesn't
it just even though it's validated at
the end like great Greg you go right
back into that same feeling yes and
there's only there's one time I was
doing like a tour for my book and I was
about to go like speak in front of
people at Barnes and Noble
right I was very nervous I felt so much
pressure I was so scared I was shaking
and the there was a person there a
publicist person
um who said like okay if you really feel
like you're gonna throw up or faint just
look at me and I'll come get you and
that was so disarming to me because then
I was like I felt validated I felt like
okay I have a Lifeline I'm gonna be okay
so that's like the one like thing that I
had sort of remembered